what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are we're wrapping up
blackest night we have like this one and
there's another video today and then
we're done and we're gonna be finished
with our double uploads on on blackest
night as much as I love it I kind of
want to return to just doing like Green
Lantern videos once a week because I
think it gets a little weird over
saturating with Green Lantern's too many
Green Lantern videos drives everybody
crazy but anyway so for those of you
guys who were new the long and short of
this is that blackest night is basically
the end times is this idea that these
Black Lantern rings it has kind of risen
out of nowhere and the result is that
they're bonding themselves to people who
are both living in debt now with those
who are living it's basically those who
have died and then they were supposed to
move on to the afterlife but they didn't
DC editorial decided to bring him back
but within the confines of DC story
itself which is to say within the DC
universe it was this idea that the
entity of death nekron had stepped in
and kept those characters from dying and
so at this moment right now there are
two conflicts taking place the first one
is out in space involving the Green
Lantern Corps and the second is on earth
and on earth it's largely just the
superheroes that are there doing the
best they can to stave off against this
conflict it's members of the Sinestro
Corps Green Lantern Corps and so on and
so forth it's all the cores on earth
trying to stop the end of all things
because remember if the black Lantern's
basically bond rings to everybody then
the emotional spectrum will effectively
cease to exist
all beings everywhere will feel no
emotion whatsoever and the result is
that they will just sort of Usher in
this new era of Darkness the universe
itself will effectively die now what we
covered up to this point was the idea
that the superheroes were just trying to
stave off this eventualities they were
trying to stave off the idea that
everything was gonna die but in the
middle of their attempts to stop the
being necron they're subtly met by the
arrival of the spectre now the spectre
is a character that we haven't really
talked about too often we haven't really
done a whole lot with him when it came
to the spectre as a concept he goes all
the way back to like 1940 I mean he's
one of DC's oldest characters he was
created by Jerry Siegel I think it was
and the whole idea was that the spectre
was designed to be really one of the
earliest components of DC's whole
mythological side which is to say all
their demons and angels and and so on
and so forth but the spectre is the
living embodiment of basically God's
vengeance in the sense that there was a
guy named Jim Corrigan he was shot in
the line of duty instead of dying he
basically became a host for the spectre
and so the spectre basically just travel
around Earth in the DC landscape and
finds those individuals who have been
judged by God as basically being
condemned to damnation and then just
whisks them away and that's really about
it but the whole idea with the specter
is that in the early days he was crazy
powerful I mean he was almost
reality-warping godly powerful now when
crisis on Infinite Earths going forward
if you know after the mid 1980s
DCD powered him quite a bit but the
whole idea was in the Jim Corrigan
inspector dichotomy reigned supreme for
quite some time but different writers
did different things with the character
but the whole idea was that in the
post-crisis landscape DC actually killed
off the character of Jim Corrigan the
whole idea here is that following the
death of Jim Corrigan there was a story
called day of judgment and even then
there were some you know stories that
took place in between there where it was
basically the question of what is DC
going to do with the character of the
spectre what are they gonna do with the
character of Hal Jordan remember and
9:23 Hal Jordan basically became
parallax and we'll talk more about that
here in a minute but the idea was that
you know how Jordan basically became
this corruptible guy and DC was removing
him to replace him with Kyle Rayner and
so it made sense to basically merge you
know Hal Jordan and the spectre together
which is where all that stuff happened
but the whole idea was that there was a
sort of bouncing around that took place
with the spectre concept now in terms of
how it exists now a Hal Jordan and the
spectre split from one another it
presented itself as the same scenario
what did they do at the specter if he
doesn't have a host and so what this did
is it introduced a character by the name
of Crispin Allen and the whole idea was
a Crispin Allen was basically this guy
who was a partner of the character of
Renee Montoya Crispin Allen is basically
the new host for the spectre and is one
of those interesting scenarios because
what this does is it actually leads us
into the concept of parallax
because the spectre is designed to be
the living embodiment of God's vengeance
and because the spectre while he is
weaker than he's historically been is
still an incredibly powerful being what
this means is that none of the heroes on
earth can actually stop this Spectre now
in terms of the fact that Crispin Allen
was killed and then became a host for
the for the spectre this meant that
Crispin Allen could actually become a
block Lantern and that's what we saw
over the course of the blackest night
story is he basically saw a ring bond
itself to Crispin Allen and so what we
learned over the course of blackest
night is that a set of the Black Lantern
rings actually resurrecting the dead
instead what they were doing is they
were bonding themselves to the corpses
of those who died and then basically
duplicating them and so in this end
this black lantern Spectre is not
actually The Spectre instead it's the
ring creating an image of The Spectre
and the way that we know that is because
of the fact that with Hal Jordan
basically sitting down and saying we
cannot defeat the specter on our own
because of the sheer power that he has
he says the only way to do this is to
bring back an entity that I've never
wanted to bring back again what he does
is he brings back parallax but the whole
idea was that in the early 1990s because
how Jordan is a Green Lantern was
largely just not popular with readers DC
decided to kill him off and replace him
with more of a younger vibrant version
of the Green Lantern concept DC launched
a story called Emerald Twilight and it
will Twilight basically dealt with the
idea that Hal Jordan had returned to
Earth after the events of the death of
Superman only to find out that cyborg
Superman had obliterated the entirety of
coast city alongside the villain Mongol
the result was that Hal Jordan used his
ring to basically recreate Koh City he
was chastised for it he went absolutely
nuts and then he interned wiped out the
entirety of the Green Lantern Corps
absorb the energy of the central power
battery which is where the Green
Lantern's get their power from and then
killed almost all the Guardians except
for ganthet and then absorbed all their
energies into himself and just started
calling himself parallax when writer
Geoff Johns took over the Green Lantern
story what he did is he modified the
original Emerald Twilight story what he
established as he said okay historically
the Green Lantern's have always been
weak to the color yellow what he did is
he came back and he said what actually
happened is somewhere along the line the
Olivia embodiment of fear in the DC
Universe known as a parallax it had been
captured by the guardians of the
universe and confined within the Green
Lantern central power battery and what
this did is an allowed parallax to
basically contaminate the Green Lantern
energy which is what made them weak to
the color yellow and so what this meant
was that during the events of Emerald
Twilight when Hal Jordan came home and
his city was destroyed and so on and so
forth it basically put him in a weak
state of mind and working alongside
parallax
Sinestro devised this plan to allow the
parallax entity to possess Hal Jordan
and that's what happened that's the new
updated origin of the Hal Jordan
parallax concept now the reason why this
ties into the whole concept of the
spectre is because when the events of
Emerald Twilight ended and Hal Jordan
was no longer the character of parallax
Kyle Rayner was already the Green
Lantern and so DC did not want to bring
Hal Jordan back because if they did
what it meant is they would have had two
characters vying for the position of
Green Lantern and new fans who liked how
our life Kyle Rayner didn't want to see
how Jordan returned and so what they did
is they launched the day of judgment
story which saw Hal Jordan inspect her
merging into a singular being and it
stayed that way until green lantern
rebirth and in split Hal Jordan Spectre
again and so that's why all that stuff
sort of ties in together and that's why
all this is kind of important but at
this moment right now when Hal Jordan
basically goes back to being parallax
when he returns to being a host for the
parallax entity he's not as powerful as
he was but the goal of him returning to
the role of parallax is not for the
purpose of destroying the specter it's
for the purpose of bringing the spectre
out when Hal Jordan as parallax begins
fighting the spectre and essentially
tears him open what we end up finding is
that within this black Lantern shell is
the actual spectre himself alongside
Christmas Allen so they're basically
being held captive and their power is
being channeled and used by the Black
Lantern ring now following this defeat
of black lantern Spector what is up
happening is it's basically just Hal
Jordan being split in half again because
Hal Jordan is still in there he has an
emotional tie to Carol Ferris Carol
Ferris was a love interest of Hal Jordan
for years and years and years and years
and so because of this it's basically
this idea that the spectre can seize
hold of parallax and pull the entity out
of Hal Jordan but only if somebody is
pulling the other direction and that's
why that works is because it's basically
Carol Ferris here abs on to the Hal
Jordan concept and pulls on him while
the parallax entity is being pulled out
and it means that Hal Jordan goes back
to his normal self
the other half of this is actually the
actions of Atrocitus of the Red Lanterns
but one of the things that Jeff John
hits on here is the idea of the Red
Lantern entity and so what this is going
to do is lead into you all these
different entities now we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but for right
now what this also hits that is the idea
that no one can really escape the might
of a Lantern ring so long as a being is
sentient if a ring can bond to them they
can become part of that court and in
this instance what Atrocitus actually
tries to do is bond the spectre to the
Red Lantern ring but it doesn't last it
lasts maybe for like a panel or two and
the reason for this is because when a
Red Lantern ring takes over a host a
certain amount of time has to pass
before that person is completely
converted into a Red Lantern
but in this instance because the spectre
is so powerful he doesn't fall prey his
heart's not replaced or anything along
those lines
but the reason why Atrocitus did this is
because Atrocitus is actually believed
that the spectre is basically the Red
Lantern entity that Atrocitus has been
looking for the Red Lantern equivalent
to like parallax and so because of this
the spectre Sulli responds by saying you
can't make me into a Red Lantern but
I've met the entity that you're looking
for and if you find it it will kill you
it's this idea that Geoff Johns is
setting the stage for this huge
expansive revelation of all these
different things that will come later on
down the line with regards to all these
different cores now with regards to the
spectrum self what he ends up doing is
actually trying to take out Necron but
this is a major limitation of the
spectre while the spectre used to be
this godly powerful being back in the
40s in the 50s and 60s and 70s nowadays
he's basically just a guy that shows up
and just whisks the souls of the Damned
off and that's it that's really all
there is to it and this instance Necron
does not have a soul and so in this
instance because of the fact that Necron
does not actually have a soul for the
specter to take the specter is basically
powerless against him not only this
necron actually whisks the spectre away
what it means is the right hand of God
cannot stop necron now if the presence
chose to step in sure like that would be
the end of it and necron would be
defeated but you know in this
circumstance the story needs to be told
so aside from pulling in you know one of
those caveats that's really about it
things wrap up pretty fast now with
regards to the whole idea of Guy Gardner
and the Green Lantern Corps one of the
things that we had talked about in the
last video was that the Green Lantern
Corps itself at least what was left of
their number due to the fact that so
many of them were being killed by black
Lantern's and then being converted into
black Lantern's themselves Kyle Rayner
one of the more popular Green Lantern's
was believed to have been killed and in
his rage Guy Gardner had lost his mind
and then was bonded with a Red Lantern
ring and what we're seeing right now is
this transitionary period where Guy
Gardner is basically at a point where if
the ring is pulled off he will
essentially die the various Green
Lantern's are basically trying to find a
way to bring Kai Gardner down and then
basically cure him because remember one
person becomes a Red Lantern they're
just mindless rage and so the Green
Lantern planet Mogo is actually able to
offer some measure of a reprieve and
it's really cool the way this happens
what mobile basically does is force a
guy gardener to basically have this
inner fight with himself which is to say
the green lantern part of himself that
recalls all the great memories and love
interest he's had and different things
like that and the red lantern part of
himself that really does kind of feeds
on all the horrible experiences that
he's had the idea here is to actually
offer some measure of a distraction to
allow the Green Lantern's to muster
their number and then subdue a guy
gardner and so what this does is it
allows Mogo the planet to actually pull
Guy Gardner down inside of him and then
begin releasing all these different
leeches now this is the second way in
which a person can be cured when it
comes to red lantern rage in truth while
this does purge a lot of the red lantern
energy out of them one of the things
that's immediately made clear is that
Guy Gardner is not completely cured of
the red lantern energy if his ring was
removed he would die and so the only way
to really bring him back the only way to
restore some measure of normalcy is to
bring him to a blue lantern because blue
lanterns are the ones that basically go
through this sort of cleansing process
and they're the only way in which a
person who is a red lantern can safely
have their ring removed and then go back
to being part of whatever core they were
before so again this basically brings
the Green Lantern Corps directly to
earth where this final battle will take
place and so again transitioning back to
earth proper while all these different
heroes are basically trying to defeat
necron at the end of the day they're not
able to defeat a being of such intense
power the arrival of Guy Gardner and the
other Green Lantern's the fact that the
blue lanterns are here all the different
cores have united under the idea of
trying to defeat necron but none of them
can do it because he's just such an
astronomically powerful being not only
that we end up getting an explanation as
to why it was that necron stepped in the
way and kept all these different
superheroes from dying over the course
of their lives the reason for this is
because necron has been seeking
something out and the only way he can
attain it is to actually kill one of the
guardians of the universe
andin used their blood in a ritual of
sorts and then in turn wake up something
called the life entity and so when it
comes to the to the life entity itself
it's essentially this idea that this is
kind of a representation of where life
originated and that's one of the big
revelations that comes out of this is
because it was believed that the
guardians of the universe the mountains
were the first race in the unit
but what this reveals to us is life did
not start with the mountains it started
on earth the Malthusians cover that up
they basically took the life entity
buried it in the core of the earth and
then wrote it out of history in order to
one ensure that people would believe
that they were the original source of
life in the universe the first race to
pop up and to to maintain their power
and to protect the life entity to keep
an event like this from actually
happening it is designed to show the
guardians of the universe as beings who
were full of hubris who believed that
they legitimately have the right to
decide how the universe should progress
and so it basically would have brought
the entire foundation of what it is that
made the guardians of the universe as
they are crashing down around them and
people would have just lost trust in
them entirely not to mention the Green
Lantern Corps probably would have
vacated but more so than that
the life entity is the representation of
life in the DC universe and if somebody
harnesses that power they would become
God and that's the fear the other thing
that the guardians of the universe have
that if people knew the life entity
exists it would be like this great gold
rush for the power of the life entity it
could potentially even uh sure in this
massive Universal Civil War of people
who were coveting all this power and
whoever came out on top no matter what
their intentions were they would be
virtually unstoppable and so in this
instance were Hal Jordan rationalizes
this is okay well we have to seize the
seize the power of the life entity in
order to basically destroy necron in the
Black Lantern Corps thousand Estero
steps in and Thal Sinestro says no you
had parallax I get the life entity and
so what we end up having here is
basically the rise of the first white
Lantern in the form of thousand estro
who seizes the power of the life entity
itself but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb pork if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
you